FEMALE SPEAKER: Today's
speaker, Dick Bolles,
is the author of, "What
Color Is Your Parachute?,"
a practical manual for
job hunters and career
changers-- the most popular
job hunting book in the world.
He updates "Parachute"
every year.
The newest edition is this year.
The "Parachute" book has
been sold more than 10
million copies to date.
It has been translated
into 20 languages,
and is sold in 26 countries--
is used in 26 countries.
Dick was a minister
for many years
before he became a writer.
And prior to that, he majored
in chemical engineering at MIT
and graduated with a degree
in physics in Harvard.
Dick and his son, Gary Bolles,
are no strangers to Google.
Both of them have been
involved in Google's Zeitgeist
conference in the past.
Today we have asked
Dick to help us
with our future--
each of our futures.
What are you going
to do in five years?
Here I am happy to present
to you Dick Bolles.
DICK BOLLES: Thank
you very much.
Thank you, Optimists.
I always am amused that
we clap before we've
heard one word out of
the person's mouth.
I appreciate all of
you being here today.
I know there are other things
you could do with your hour
at noon.
For me, it's a
stroll in the park.
I live nearby.
I live 58 minutes away in
the East Bay, Danville.
And I always love coming
to the Google Campus
with hardly a single
face over the age of 30,
because it's nice to see
the youth of America.
How many of you have
given any thought
to what you're going to be
doing five years from now?
Could you raise your hand if
you have given it thought?
Ah, that's impressive.
I wouldn't have thought that.
Very interesting.
Of course, it's
hard to figure out
what you're going to be
doing five years from now.
I was thinking back in my
own life, when I was 40,
I could never have predicted
in a million years what
I was going to be doing
just five years from then.
At that time, I
was cannon pastor
at Grace Cathedral
in San Francisco,
and in the next
years, I was fired.
In the next years, I was hired
to visit every college campus
in the nine Western states.
I was hired to find out what
was bothering those people.
And I remember we had a
meeting of my colleagues--
I had nine other
denominations working with me,
I was the Episcopalian.
And the others were the
Methodist, Pres-- everything
you would think of.
And we had this meeting
at Glide Memorial Church,
just using their offices.
And they said, "Dick, you're
sitting nearest the blackboard.
Would you put up what we need
to talk about during our meeting
today?"
And I said, "Sure."
And they said, "Somebody
needs to go to Pocatello."
That was Idaho.
We had a firebrand
campus minister there
that was always causing
trouble, and we always
had to go and soothe the
feathers of the administration.
So I put up on the
blackboard, "Pocatello."
And then they said,
"Dick, we have
to discuss the date
for our next meeting."
So I put, "Next meeting."
And they said, "Dick, we need
to talk about the people who
are going to have to bail out."
And I wrote, "What color
is your parachute?"
Because I was playing with
the words, "bail out,"
and I thought, it's
either a leaky rowboat
where you're taking the water
out before you get swamped,
or it's somebody jumping
out of an airplane.
I've always had a
very playful mind.
I like the mind
that God's given me.
But I like most of all
about it, it's very playful.
In 2002, I died, literally.
I stopped breathing.
My fingernails and lips
turned black, and so on.
And they revived me,
which I was grateful for,
and so I had been dreaming.
I lay down to sleep, and
I died during my sleep.
And so I thought--
when I woke up,
I thought I was
still in the dream.
And all these
white-coated people
were rushing back and forth.
And I thought, this is odd.
I've never had
this dream before.
So I looked at them, and
one of them came up to me
and the first question
he said is, "Can you
tell me your name?"
And I said, "Dick Bolles."
And then he said, "Can you
tell me your social security
number?"
And immediately, because
God gave me a bright mind,
I realized he was
testing the viability
of my intelligence in my brain.
So as I said, the one
thing I love about the mind
that God gave me is, I
love how playful it is.
So I said, I'm going to play
with the next question he
asks me.
So he asked me, "What's
your social security?"
And I reeled it off.
And then I was ready
for him-- and this
was when George Bush was in the
White House-- he said, "Can you
tell me the name of the
President of the United
States?"
And I said, "Of
course-- chowder head."
And at first, he thought
I was really gone.
And then he realized
I was joking.
So, and my father-- I
got this from my father.
My father was
tremendously playful,
and famously, his last words,
as he lay on his bed dying,
were, "Thank God I won't have
to go to the bathroom anymore."
So I love that kind
of playfulness.
So when we had that meeting
and I wrote that silly title
on the blackboard for the
item that we had to discuss,
some years later, within
the five, when I was 43,
I wrote a book on what I-- I
put together all the research
I could find about why
people got sick of their jobs
and what they did when they
got sick of their jobs.
And I went and interviewed
people around the country.
I travel-- I kept a log.
I travelled 68,000 miles, and
back and forth, back and forth,
back and forth, because I had
a huge travel budget from these
10 different Protestant
denominations that I was
working for.
And so eventually, I
put it all together.
I just published it,
self-published it.
And I took it down to a
copy shop in San Francisco,
and I said, "Can you
bind this together
and make it be a book?"
And they said, "Sure."
And then I tried to think
of what title to put on it,
and they said, "Well, what
title do you want to put on it?"
And I thought of-- I remembered
the laughter when that item had
come up on the blackboard at
that meeting two years before
this, and so I said,
"I'm going to call it,
'What Color is Your Parachute?'"
And nobody in the
world could figure out
what on earth I meant.
So they started to think,
well, it's an allegory.
Maybe he means, is it yellow,
are you too afraid to jump?
And blah, blah, blah.
It Didn't mean anything--
that's the trouble.
It was, and is, a joke.
Now, it shot to the top
of the best seller list.
I don't know why.
And the average book
sells, believe it or not,
in its lifetime, total
sales of the average book
in this country is 3,000 copies.
And if it sells-- they studied
how many business books were
published two years
ago, and in that year,
1,000 business books were
published, and 62 of them
sold more than 3,000.
Only 62 out of the whole 1,000.
So when you hit sales like 10
million, people pay attention,
or they want to know why.
And it isn't the
charm of the writer,
and it isn't the knowledge that
he's got his head, or her head.
It reveals a vacuum-- a
vacuum in our schools.
I remember going to
Hastings Law School.
They asked me to speak
there some time back.
And I said, "How do you
measure the number of lawyers
you're producing so that it
just fits the number that
are needed out there?"
And they said, we
make no such attempt.
We don't try to match
the number of people
of people we're educating with
what the job market wants.
That's not our concern.
Somebody wants to be
trained as a lawyer,
she or he can come here,
and we will train them.
And that is the
problem with so much
of what goes on
with our schools.
It teaches us, again
and again, to think.
Teaches us to store vast kinds
of knowledges in our head.
But it doesn't tell
us a word about what
to do when you want to move
where the rubber hits the road.
So the book has
become so popular
because of the vacuum in
our educational system.
No book in the world would
sell 10 million copies
if the schools covered that
same topic in the curriculum.
So that's always been
fascinating to me.
Now, five years
from now-- how do
we figure out what
we're going to be
doing five years from now?
Well, the trouble is,
I'd like to sort of,
with my training in technique
pursuits at MIT and Harvard,
I like to observe
what people do.
Never mind telling them,
"Hey, you should go do this,
you should go do that."
I like to see, what do they do?
How do they act?
And I've discovered--
over the 40 years
I've been in this field now--
I've discovered that people
approach the subject of, what
am I going to be doing five
years from now in
three different ways.
The first way is to
ignore the subject.
I mean, luck, I guess,
would be the summary of it.
They decide, I'm going
to depend on luck.
I'll find out where I
am five years from now,
and that will help me to figure
out then what I'm going to do.
Now, that's kind of
like surfing, isn't it?
It's like saying,
whatever are going
to be the waves that will come
along then, I'll leap on them
and I'll try to take
advantage of them.
But it's going to be luck.
That's going to guide
how I figure out
what I'm going to be
doing five years from now.
And then I observed by watching
a lot of people over time,
that there was another way in
which some people approached
the subject, and that was,
they would say to themselves,
"I'll know it when I see it."
That was famously
enshrined in "Mamma Mia"
where she had three
fathers and she
didn't know which one
was really her father,
and she said, "I'll know
him when I see him."
As you recall from--
those of you who
saw the play or the movie,
that didn't work out.
So but some people say that.
They say, I'm going to approach
this the way I approach life.
I'm going to keep looking
around, and if I see something,
and it's really the kind
of thing I want to do,
I'll know it when I see it.
And then there's
the third approach
that people take
as an alternative
if they don't like luck and
they don't like intuition.
They say, "I'll
figure out what I'm
going to be doing
five years from now
by doing some forethought.
I'll do some planning
now, right now.
I'll figure out some
things about myself,
and I'll let that guide me."
Now, that's fine if we
called it designing.
It's not so hot if
we call it planning,
because you cannot plan
five years from now.
You have no idea whether
there we'll be a war,
or what kind of natural
catastrophes come along,
or what new technologies.
You cannot plan,
but you can design.
Now one of the ways in which
I designed in my own life,
and I'll use it as an
illustration of what
I mean-- I used to
camp with my family.
Gary, one of my sons, is
here in the front row.
I always try to bring my
own audience in case nobody
else show up.
So the way we went
camping, we did camp
in 40 out of the 50 states while
my four kids were growing up.
And when we would go camping, we
would say, what might we need?
Well, we might need
a long tent pole,
because the car had
a very bad radiator,
and when we hit the desert
regions of the West,
sometimes the car
would overheat and you
needed a poll to push the cap
off the top of the radiator
and let all the water spout out.
And then of course,
you had to have
a container with the
water in it to replenish
what went out of the radiator.
So we didn't plan,
but we tried to say,
what are the kinds of things
we're going to run into?
And what might we need to
deal with those problems
or challenges?
So that's what, if you're
going to think about-- I'm
going to give some
forethought to my I'm
going to be doing
five years from now,
the best you can hope for
is designing-- gathering
together-- under
your own auspices
and under your own watch--
gathering together anything
you might need to
deal with what's
going to happen
five years from now.
So how do you do that?
Well, let's go back to all
the different approaches.
We said that either
people are going
to decide what they're going
to do five years from now when
they get there-- that's luck.
Or they're going to keep a
watchful eye, because they
think if they see
an opportunity,
they'll know it
when they see it.
So it's either luck, or
intuition, or designing.
Now what do you
have to do to make--
let's say we are fully
trained by the computer,
and our whole brain has
rewired itself a little bit.
We know we're going to be
looking for keywords all
the time.
We're just going to
be scanning quickly,
we're going to be
looking for keywords.
So what we need to
do, if we're going
to start to think about what is
going to happen with our lives
five years from now, is
to watch for what keywords
have to command our attention.
So if you're going to
take the approach of luck,
and a lot of people
do, and it's no shame.
It's just the way they
prefer to operate.
If you're going to take the
approach to luck and say,
I'll just wait, what luck
is going to depend on
is intersections.
The more people you run
into, the more likely
you'll have luck, so-called.
So what we have to
observe, if we're
going to take that
approach to what
we're going to be doing
five years from now,
we have to make
sure there are more
intersections in our lives.
That means a bunch of stuff.
It mean certainly paying
attention to whatever meetings
and stuff we go to in
the course of our work.
It means paying attention
to getting on LinkedIn.
There's also a nice app, which
I like a lot, and some of you
may not know it, called
Jobs With Friends.
If you're on
Facebook or LinkedIn,
you tell Jobs With
Friends-- you can search on
that, I don't remember
the exact URL--
and it will ask for you
to dump, or let them dump,
all the people you're linked to,
and then all the people you're
friends with.
And it will catalog
where they're working,
it'll catalog whether
there are any openings
at that particular
place where they work.
It'll allow you to put up an
alert beside the companies that
look interesting.
And the great thing
about it is, you already
have a contact there.
Because you're starting
with your friends.
You're starting with your
contacts, and then saying,
and what kinds of opportunities
might these friends
give me access to?
So Jobs With Friends
is one way to do it.
Checkster is another.
Checkster is spelled
C-H-E-C-K-S-T-E-R,
just what you thought.
Checkster is run by a friend
of mine named Yves Lermusi
L-E-M-U-S-I.
And what you do there is,
you go to their home page,
it's Checkster.com, I think.
And scroll down, and there
is a box that says My Talent.
And you click on that.
It allows you to designate
six to twelve-- or more,
if you want-- colleagues
that you have,
friends that you have, people
that know you like a book.
And over your
signature, Checkster
will send them an
email asking them
to answer some questions about
you-- about your work habits,
and that sort of thing.
And when they get it,
they give you seven days,
they give the friends of
yours seven days to answer,
and when they answer,
they take the names off,
and they mash it all together
and send you a summary.
It's for your eyes only,
it's all done by machine,
and it's free.
So that's one way, also to look
at how to build connections
in terms of, how do
I relate to people?
How could I relate
better to people?
Because if I'm going to
go down the route of luck
to figure out what I'm going to
be doing five years from now,
I'd better have as many
connections as possible
so that my luck increases.
On the other hand,
if you decide,
no, I'm not going to
just depend on luck.
I'm going to be alert.
I'm going to start to
really pay attention.
I'm going to live by intuition.
I do that in my rest
of my life, I'll
do it with five years from now.
OK.
What does intuition depend on?
Well, a good example would be
the husband who comes home,
and he tells his wife
how much he loves her,
and he showers her with flowers,
and brings her chocolates,
and she says, "You're having
an affair, aren't you?"
And he says, "How
did you know that?"
And she said, "Because you
never bring me chocolates,
you never bring me
flowers, blah, blah, blah."
This is, of course, is
an exaggerated allegory.
But the point I'm
making is, intuition
depends on what you notice.
You notice what the benchmark
is in your relationships
with people, and in your
relationships with situations,
and then when you see a
deviation from that benchmark
that you've noticed
again and again operates,
suddenly it occurs to you,
hey, something's going on here.
Because it's different.
So what do you observe when
you are depending on intuition?
Well, you have to determine
whether, generally, you
know this now-- right now--
what do you like to work with?
Do you like to work with
just information most of all?
Or do you like to work
with people most of all?
with things, like computers
and stuff most of all?
Then once you decide that,
well, I like all three, yes.
But push-- push comes to
shove, which of those three
do you give preference to?
Which of those three do you
establish a priority for?
Well, I think I most like to
work with data, or information.
OK.
In that case, then what you pay
attention to in the next years
until you hit five
years from now,
is you pay attention
to everything
you run into that has to do
with jobs dealing with data.
Because at least you've begun
to focus down a little bit.
And when you see
deviations, like, oh that
sounds really interesting,
I've never heard that before,
you start to pay
large attention.
Now let's say you want
to be a little more
in charge of your life,
so you're going to decide,
well, I'm going to approach
five years from now
by doing some actual stuff now.
The question becomes,
what stuff should you do?
Well, a good thing to do is
an inventory of yourself.
And that sounds
ridiculous, because you've
lived with yourself
these many years,
and you know
yourself pretty well.
So why on earth would you
do an inventory of yourself?
Why not somebody you don't know?
Well, the answer is
because we've already
started to put
ourselves in boxes.
You probably know, there were
two articles in the "New York
Times" these past
three months about how
to get hired at Google.
And one of the points
of they made was,
they like to interview people
who could figure things out.
And I had another thought,
which I've forgotten what it is,
but it'll come back.
So you're going to
do a self-inventory.
What are you going
to ask yourself?
You're going to ask yourself,
how have I put myself in boxes?
How have I said, oh, I'm a tech.
Or oh, I'm a coder.
Or, I do programming, or
I do public relations,
and that's who I am.
You need to have a refuge
from the concepts and pictures
of yourself you've been
living with thus far.
If you're going to learn,
you first have to unlearn.
Very few schools
talk about that.
There's so many nutty
ideas floating around
that we are exposed
to since we were
tiny kids, that we
have to unlearn.
And one of them is ourselves.
What's your picture of yourself?
If we're locked into
the idea that I am this,
or I am that, that
inhibits us from being
able to be creative
about what we're going
to do with our lives one year
from now, never mind five.
So you need an inventory that
will sort of say, not I'm this
and I'm that, but
an inventory that
starts out with an assumption.
And the assumption
is, I am a person.
I am a person who--
dot, dot, dot.
And there are seven ways in
which you can look at yourself,
and the seven ways
are in my book.
In fact, I invented
this because I
was helping a bunch of
people in 1977, I think,
back when dinosaurs
were roaming the Earth,
and I invented this
inventory for them.
It's in my book,
which, incidentally,
I suppose I should do some
crass commercialism-- my book is
for sale in the
back of the room,
and it's only 5 bucks today.
That's less than it usually is.
And there's a thing in
the book, and also I
have a workbook as
well, which is not here.
If you're going to figure out
what you're going to be doing
five years from now, you
cannot possibly plan that.
But you can gather
all the stuff you
think you might
need when you get
to five years from now, that
might be helpful and useful.
And the first thing you
gather-- when I was camping,
the first thing we
gathered was a tent.
That was obviously our priority.
When you are trying
to figure out
what you're going to
do five years from now,
and you've decided not to
go down the road of luck,
not to go down the
road of just intuition,
but you've decide to
really try to design,
gather stuff you may need.
The first thing you need most of
all is rethinking who you are.
Because what you're going to
do flows from who you are,
especially if it's appropriate
work and meaningful
work for you.
So in this inventory, you write
stories-- seven stories-- not
all at once.
One at a time, then
try to figure out
what that story tells you.
Now, in the workbook, and
also in the main book,
we take you down to
the level of skills.
Why?
Because the further down
toward the atomic level
in your understanding
of yourself
that you go-- the
further down you
go-- the more
flexibility you have.
For example, I was in Spain
a couple of years ago,
and I was helping them-- they
were retraining construction
workers to be computer
repair people.
That's most training programs.
You've done one thing,
it's sort of not
demanded by culture
and society anymore,
so you learn one new thing.
No.
That is a horrible way
to go about retraining.
What you want to
have is flexibility.
And flexibility depends
on getting down as far
as you can to the atomic level.
What's the most basic unit that
makes up this thing called you?
And the most basic
unit is your skills.
You have a brain,
and the brain can
do two things-- the
brain can store stuff.
You know a lot about
this, you know quite a bit
about that-- the brain
is a storage area.
But the brain also has another
function-- it can think.
It can say, this is a
pathway I will take.
This doesn't make any sense.
This new data comes in,
I've got to integrate that
into my understanding of
what I'm supposed to do here.
You can think.
And thinking is one of the
skills-- one of the skills
you need to pay attention to.
What kind of thinking
do like to do?
Do you like to synthesize?
Do you like to break
down and analyze?
How do you like
to use your brain?
What parts of the
different skill
sets that a brain has, just
looking at it as a model.
What are the different
things a brain can do,
and which of those
do you love to do?
So if you're going to design
how you're going to figure out
what you're going to be
doing five years from now,
you need to have an
inventory of yourself.
That inventory needs
to depend on stories.
You need to break those
stories down to as close
to the atomic level of
braindom as you can.
And that means skills.
What are your favorite,
favorite, favorite, favorite
skills?
Never mind what the
marketplace wants.
Who cares?
You can always find ways to
persuade people to give you
work that lets you
use your skills if you
are enthusiastic about them.
If any of you have to do
interviewing now or later
in your life, if two equally
competent people come
into the room, you will always
end up hiring, instinctively,
if you're good at
it, you'll always
end up hiring the one who has
a lot of enthusiasm and passion
for what they're doing.
They didn't just choose this
because they can do it--
they choose this because
they love to do it.
And that's what your inventory
is about-- figuring out,
what do you love the most?
What do you love to do?
What knowledges do you
love to use the most?
And you figure this out
now because then this
becomes some useful
information to you
that gives you flexibility.
I did my own analysis
of my own skills,
and I had to write them out,
because I don't remember them.
First of all, I'm
very good at writing.
Secondly, I'm very
good at researching.
I spend four hours
a day researching.
I'm very good at teaching.
And I'm good at speaking.
So writing, speaking, analyzing,
teaching, researching.
Because those are basic
atomic elements of who I am,
they give me flexibility.
I could be a writer, or
I could be a speaker,
or I could be an analyzer,
or I could be a teacher,
or I could be a researcher.
When you get down to the
atomic level of understanding
who you are, you then have
much greater flexibility.
You're not committed just
to become a computer repair
person.
You have many choices
about what route
you're going to take, as long
as your inventory has gotten you
down to that level of
understanding of who you are.
And that's what you need.
So when we think
about, what am I
going to be doing five
years from now, I mean,
I haven't got a clue
for my own life.
I know I'll be with
my lovely wife,
I know I'll treasure
my lovely family,
I know I will always be
searching for ways to help
people, because
that's in my DNA.
I love to help
people a lot, but I
can't be more
specific than that.
I don't know what
new technologies
are going to come along.
I do try to always adopt them.
I'm sorry I'm not an Apple
man and not an Android man,
but otherwise I try
to adopt new stuff.
And so when we think
about our lives,
think carefully how you're
going to understand yourself,
because your question of what
are you in five years now,
depends on who
you are right now.
Thanks very much.
[APPLAUSE]